okay so you can see just like before
right you've got two values here right
that define where you are there have to
be two values because you're in a
two-dimensional space here what she
values are different so I'm going to
give them Sundays right I don't have X&Y
I have R and theta okay so what's our R
in this scheme here it's cold
r because it's about the rates right but
because we're going to start thinking
about when we were joined you have to
draw this but we were starting to
represent complex numbers on our eigen
diagrams for the first time
circles are nowhere to be found they're
kind of implied if anything so if I said
3 plus I ok so it's like I don't need to
think in terms of circles here right so
even though I'm gonna keep on using this
are pretty rule because there's why why
do this new one I do want to introduce a
new word to indicate it because it
doesn't make much sense to say radius
when I'm referring to this late because
radius of what I need to introduce a
circle where there's there's those of
necessity to do that okay so we say R is
the modulus modulus so mo d UL mu s is
the BA juice which is the distance from
the origin
our is the magis the distance from the
origin and thea we also give a special
they - we call thinner the argument
really argument is actually a very broad
word which means you know something
would you stick into a function okay but
in in mathematics it seems this is like
the main place the argument is used so
even though strictly speaking I could
say you know if f of X equals x squared
plus 5 I can legitimately say X is the
argument in that statement up there okay
but that's that's more of like a
software into the engineering point of
view when I say argument this classroom
I'm referring exclusively to this angle
business okay
theater is the argument the angle
subtended from now where is this where
where do we when we describe this now we
actually have some symbols of some
language now in the past I used to have
to say the positive x-axis right I'm not
on an x axis here anymore though in the
complex plane what's its called this is
the realizes right this is okay so I'm
going to borrow some of the language and
notation that I've used before and I'm
going to say the Amos attended from the
positive real right this is my symbol
that I'm using for real and for positive
axis dump okay so this is a huge new
idea yes yes it does now why does it
have to be from the positive real axis I
want you to think back to what we're
doing our multiplications right and you
notice when I multiply by numbers which
way do they go and necessarily when you
start just putting you know the example
we chose us I but you're going from here
anti-clockwise right you're going you're
going that way okay so therefore it has
to start from that side in order to make
sense for it to go in that direction
okay otherwise that I think it all goes
backwards okay so that's why we begin
there okay so now a name for this this
is in right I've got X's and Y's so you
can kind of call it Cartesian in fact
textbooks will often use this despite
the fact that this the Cartesian plane
it's a complex plane but there's no
argument as to what this is called
it's a modulus there's an argument okay
so we call this a modulus argument form
or to be a little more dream mod is a
contraction and you'll be asked to
sustain it like this
okay now drop in the air traffic me a
new complex plane places and for this
one will mainly make it first quadrant
so they don't have to be oh I see
alright now what I'm going to do excuse
me is I'm going to rehearse this result
but now you know because before we're on
the inner circle everything was real
now we're gonna stay in the complex
world and we're going to draw some
implications out of it ok so let's take
a point up here and we call this is it
right this is our complex number so
usually I would uh I would represent
this as X plus iy and that's still fine
actually you know what let's let's try
that it is still fair today that I
represent as X plus PI Y what what try
to transition away from it so I'm going
to put in place it's good enough this is
art this is now the complex plane ok so
I've left my unit circle behind even
though the unit circle is there kind of
in the background helping me understand
its peak if I have theta right this is
the argument ok this is the argument but
because it's the argument of this
particular complex number Z I'm going to
leave this like so that I have it our
language were already called the
argument of Z right finding the argument
of a complex number that's just a
function right so therefore I'm just
gonna say I I comes in or is that it ok
now I've also it got mods in where is
mod said on this diagram it's the
distance from the origin isn't it so
it's up over here it's on the hypotenuse
ok so I'm going to say aa equals mod Z
now
this mud guy here he comes up on what
and he's very very important or she so I
would love some more concise notation
for saying this round the same for this
one that it's a bit of a pain it's sort
of a modulus but still if only I had a
piece of notation that already bent
distance from somewhere to the origin
distance from somewhere to the origin oh
wait I do have notation for where a
number is and how far it is from the
origin you just haven't been calling it
modulus you've been calling it absolute
value right do you see how remember what
we talked to a dude I said there's all
these different ways to understand the
name and give it a different
representation give a different
definition I said way back did you see I
was sowing the seeds the best definition
for the absolute value of a number is
how far you from zero okay how far is
negative 5 from zero and the answer is
it's 5 away from dignity er it's not
just that I'll leave off the side it's
that I'm trying to work out distance and
distance is a positive value okay how
far is a hundred from the origin answer
hundred and so on how far is Zed from
the origin well that's the modulus by
definition now let's just fill in this a
little bit because in order to work out
this number this is a hypotenuse I know
how to find out hypotenuse I've used
pythagoras right I just need to know
what these other two lengths on okay so
let's just feel it again I've got this
horizontal 90 which is gonna be our cos
theta and I've got my vertical which is
our sine theta so that gives me this
alternative way of writing I've got a
light outside of close theta plus I sine
theta